[Musique]
poursuis tranquillement ça monte nous
sommes à 39000 nouveau qu'un tous les
jours sur une semaine qui représente
plus 50 % d'augmentation leur dire
n'est donc pas à des mesures de Georges
de couvre-feu ou de confinement ce
serait disproportionnée en revanche
a été vraiment bien préparé
l'image du jour en politique Valérie
Pécresse Éric Ciotti lors d'un déjeuner
en tête à tête une façon d'afficher de
l'harmonie après les tensions d'hier
elle signe des autographes Éric
s'approche
mais les autographes mais soudain
répète nous sommes le droit comme si
c'était un manque de sujet c'est pas
savoir si vous êtes de droite ou de
gauche le sujet c'est savoir si les
propositions que vous faites elles ont
une efficacité elles sont différentes de
ce qui voulais demander de vous
rejoindre mais aussi sa place elle est
avec nous évidemment est pas dans cette
mascarade je suis convaincu que seul
Valérie Pécresse pour abattre Emmanuel
Macron et qu'elle pourra le faire avec
des idées fort
dans les bras
c'est très très beau et on imagine tous
sortis en train de lui susurrer tu la
sens ma droite dur
après ça magnifique compagne
de Jacques Chirac auprès de Nicolas
Sarkozy
avec sa famille fusil de guerre et Père
Noël s'il te plaît apporter
[Applaudissements]
quelques jours après une nouvelle
fusillade dans une école américaine qui
a fait 4 morts dans
ses parents en cadeau de Noël
antiraciste Éric Zemmour deux son côté a
été blessé au poignet 9 jours d'ITT été
lui ont été prescrit ça veut dire que
pendant 1 ans et nous balader entre
guillemets bien sûr
pourquoi pour vendre son livre et puis
aussi pour préparer l'opinion sans doute
le discours d'Éric Zemmour a commencé
depuis quelques minutes quand au fond de
la salle des membres des SOS Racisme
provoque les militants du candidat il se
lève et temps d'écrire non au racisme
avec des t-shirt noir tout en scandant
sauce le Grand s'ensuit une scène de
violence extrême ta provocation dans une
réunion peut inciter à cela donc je
crois qu'il faut que chacun retrouve
nous aussi on est tous content il y a un
malentendu qui s'est tourné par une
petite violence non pas ça pas été quand
même
et cette violence a été bien sûr
géneration identitaire allons dans un
meeting de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
sincèrement il y a un côté provocation
inutiles qui destiné probablement a
perturbé et là je trouve que c'est pas
responsable d'un média parle de
provocation
mettre une phrase non au racisme c'est
une provocation ça devient un peu grave
quand même Sophie Dupont SMS à Tours et
Clément duché exfiltrer pour raisons de
sécurité voilà ce que scander les
militants de Zemmour
selon les informations ce projet mort à
l'origine des violences ont pu regagner
le meeting et ont même été remercié par
un membre de la sécurité